the one settling but
i guess it wouldn't work that way
because
it just wouldn't so yeah i guess i would
want him to sell
i have a question for you go ahead
do you think
that
if a woman
settles for a man
then she is more likely to cheat on him
yeah
that's exactly why i say
i
i thought i would settle for her yeah
yeah i've seen that happen i've seen
that happen because i think if a woman
feels like she's got
her top pick
she ain't risking that for no one
because she knew how hard she had to
look for him she ain't risking she ain't
risking that so but it works in reverse
if a man is settling for a woman that he
thinks he can do better he's going to
wander his eyes are going to wander and
eventually his other part
aspect though i is if that issue doesn't
look as good yeah it doesn't look good
so so let's put it this way let's let's
say you're a man in your early 30s
you've just started a career you're
doing okay but you're not doing great
here's a woman she's kind of nice
looking but she's really she's really
into she absolutely loves you you get
married
suddenly 35 40 your business is booming
you got the cars you got the house you
got the luxury you turn around and you
go you know i think i can get that
victoria's model now
um i can answer that um so what would
happen there is she'd divorce you and
she'd take off
and so and so
not just half alimony
she won't remarry so you're paying for
it until you die
so do you guys do you guys think with
that it makes sense for average men to
get married in 2022
yeah
the whole alimony situation yeah because
because women are incented you're
entering it you're entering you're
entering a contract where women are paid
to leave
you can have a penalty that has a 50
fail rate you can have a prenup i don't
know why average people don't have
prenups you have a prenup they're not
just for rich people yeah but i'm saying
that's not one it usually costs like uh
last i checked it cost like ten thousand
dollars to get a pre-nup
and so that's one barrier and then the
second barrier is that
you know
the it's not foolproof yeah they can't
they can there's a lot of ways around it
and the laws tend to favor women
so in 2022 do you think it's
fair for the average man to get married
with the laws being how they are or
women are paid to leave i wouldn't say
that's right
women go i wouldn't i don't know if
there's the right word maybe wise but
then again it's it's all dependent on
the woman you're with like
i'm pretty sure you would know her
enough before you propose to her and
yeah
do you do you think women can hide their
intentions
yeah but only for so long yeah yeah you
can yeah you can pretend for so long
like i've dated a guy who just pretended
to be very nice and very you know
gorgeous whatever and then that only
lasted for six months because okay the
the mask the veil has lifted because you
can only maintain that for so long so i
think that's a very feminine point of
view
but i
like because you're thinking like men
because men in general can only hide
their masks for so long
but women can hold them for longer and i
there's this i went to this um donovan's
convention there was a dude who was
married to a girl for years and she
divorced him and killed his dog wow
what yeah this is just
average joe
yeah wow and and so and to me i'm like
i've seen girls completely switch up so
quick like in a way i've never seen men
well i've seen one or two guys
but in debt like for the most part i see
girls do it a lot more so i can
understand like why men wouldn't want to
get married in 2022.
it's it's risky like
no matter what you do you can there's a
risk of being cheated on there's risk of
all sorts of things yeah you know
if you want security and you want to
combine your life with that person
i don't know i think it's worth getting
married yeah it's risky here now sure do
you think that if less men got married
maybe it would incentivize them to
change the laws
you know
i wouldn't say it's like for men to get
married i mean that's the thing with
like for example like men's rights
issues they don't lobby women lobby for
the things that they want men don't
gather and lobby for the things that
they want you could easily like get if
like a community of like 10 000 men if
they wanted to
get together and and lobby the
government to have like i don't know
mandatory like um dna testing when
you're born you can have that but men
don't do that there are there are men's
rights organizations actually there's
ones in the uk and there's ones in the
u.s yeah they're a few but the problem
the problem is nobody cares and men are
seen as expendable yeah so so like
people don't care when men are suffering
there's a reason there's always women's
shelters and there's no men's shelters
it's not only that i'm sorry personally
i think that will be in society today
that will be seen as very toxic if it
was put into law that a man had to get a
dna test done for every child he's got i
don't know i don't feel like the law
really looks at a man's feelings when it
comes to certain things in a
relationship in terms of their kids and
all of the other stuff as well you know
in terms of just custody as well
not saying
it's one of them ones where
the majority of the cases is what it is
majority among them that split up from
their women they ain't really worth the
salt it is what it is i get it but then
there is
the few
that come through the few that end up in
these situations where they got to leave
the misses or this and that and there's
just no protection for them at all the
mrs can say what she wants to say she
can do what she wants to do and there's
nothing out for them to for them to be
like okay i'm gonna go to my lawyer and
i'm gonna use this
but at the same time for example like
the johnny depp situation that's like a
rare situation where a guy actually
wants to
you know sue her and have her punished
or take take accountability for her
actions for example some guys you know
they break up with a girlfriend and then
she trashes her car they never call the
police
like you could just pick up your phone
and call the police because if you don't
do that she's going to do that in the
next relationship and she will never
learn and do you think men are taken
seriously when they're victims of abuse
no so why would they call the police if
they're not taken seriously i mean take
the action
so that it's but yeah but so so if
they've taken actions before and maybe
had friends that took similar actions
and the result was they weren't taken
seriously why would they do it it's not
even just that it's it's even worse than
that
men have called
the police on uh spousal abuse or women
their their wife you know girlfriend's
wife's going crazy and they're the ones
who get in han end up in handcuffs in
fact there's been cases in the united
states where they've been shot because
they've called the police and then you
know the escalation happened and and the
man ended up getting shot out of that so
it is actually physically dangerous to
call the police on your on your female
spouse if if they're you know if they're
being physical on you and i was going to
say um back to your point about men not
lobbying i think i think men do lobby
but i think they do it in different ways
and i think
i think
what we see is when women want something
changed they go into the streets they
lobby together they're very vocal
men show through their actions so if we
look at marriage a lot of men are saying
okay you know what because of the way
the laws are right now they're not in
the street saying change the laws
they're like i just want to get married
do you see what i'm saying yeah so i
think men do lori but they show through
their actions
they're not like out here oh let me
change this it's kind of more okay well
if this is how it is i'm gonna take
actions to prevent putting myself in
that position
whereas i think women what we see is
they're like no we're going to be vocal
in change and there's no right or wrong
but i think it's that
so they're not marrying it'll be a form
of lobbying yes yeah yeah okay also
there is there was a gentleman in the
house of parliament who is actually a
men's right activist and when jess
phillips was one of the mps who who
demanded to have a i forgot it was like
a woman's day or woman's week where they
discussed women's issues in parliament
when he demanded to have a men's day
that he was mocked and laughed at
because
jess phillips said every day is a man's
day in this parliament